I wonder if it's really true
What should I
do?
I'm planning on taking the top spot in October.
[Music]
Okay, it's perfect.
There is a clear difference between the food you served in the senbatsu finals and what you did in the senbatsu finals
.  I want to say it from the bottom of my heart
I want someone to say it's sweet I think I lost that spirit
[music]
Then snow
huh how did you get that far
Where do you say your passion comes from?
Can
you be so greedy just because you
want to survive the promotion exams? What are you talking about?
What I've been trying to do until today is eat it, so it's a
match or someone who's looked away
[music]
Freshly
fried Up to Hayama ah ah